so what I want to do today is just Barry
I want to introduce this to you very
quickly is and I was going to show you
this at the at the end of the last class
if we simply go to the far end of the
scale the picometer scale you see carbon
I'm not gonna start you with carbon that
is a little dull but over the next few
weeks few classes rather because we have
to do this in fast order we will go from
we will cover details of carbohydrates
amino acids nucleosides and
phospholipids and how those building
blocks are put together their properties
their ability to interact and engage in
non covalent interactions with other
molecules and the ability to make
polymers out of some of these such as
the nuclear sides and the amino acids
and the carbohydrates which then start
to create the richness of life we will
also discuss today the supramolecular
chemistry of phospholipids as they make
micelles and lipid bilayers which are
the key boundary of cells so it's very
important and then in the following week
we'll go to some of the the bigger
things like proteins nucleic acid
polymers for example hist RNA so the
course will literally do this take you
from one end of the scale to the other
so I want you to get a sense of these
dimensions I want to mention one sort of
fairly stupid thing with respect to how
chemists and biochemists talk about
certain metrics certain distances that
are pertinent that pertinence to the by
a lot to biology and biochemistry
engineers tend to talk about micrometers
and nanometers there is one unit that
chemists and biologists use quite a lot
it's the angstrom after a finish Shastra
not finished I think it was a Norwegian
and that is equivalent 10 angstrom
equals one nanometer so when you're
looking at scales we tend to talk about
Armstrong because they're a convenient
number the
don't don't get fooled by this it's you
know it can be a little bit confusing
because it's 10 to 10 to the negative 10
so nanometers 10 to the negative 9 you
know that quite frequently picometer 10
to the negative 12 micrometer negative 6
but the arms strum is just a funny unit
we use a lot and it's 10 to the negative
10 so just to make sure there's no
ambiguity about that that particular
detail okay all right so today's lecture
will focus on the molecules of life and
in particular I'm going to through the
next few classes introduce you to the
various molecules of life but first of
all we have to do a little bit to
understand chemical bonding and in
particular we want to look at both
covalent and non covalent bonding
because covalent bonding is important
it's the structure it's the framework
but non covalent bonding is what gives
us dynamics these are much weaker forces
that can be broken and remade very
readily that are essential for things
like forming the DNA duplex for folding
your proteins for associating the lipid
bilayer all of those are non covalent
courses forces and they are dynamic
because they're weak you can break one
relatively easily as long as you're
ready to make another one in its place
so I will spend a little bit of time on
that and then today we'll talk about
lipids and membranes but first of all
let me introduce you to some of the
molecules of life in this rendition
that's done by David Goodsell at Scripps
so up in the top corner here you look at
2.3 is the 3-dimensional structure of a
protein it's folded into a globular
state through no non covalent forces I
brought a little 3d model of a protein
for you to look at and take a look at
later that was one of the suggestions I
made you could coordinate printing a 3d
model as your one of your later projects
we will learn about the forces that hold
the polymer together the covalent forces
but then the non covalent forces that
make globular structures that are very
important for function they're not much
use as unraveled spagetti they're way
more useful as they're three
structure down here in the corner is a
carbohydrate it really looks pretty
pathetic in this rendition
but carbohydrates have a lot of value
particularly in energy storage but also
in things like the extracellular matrix
and as entities that single signal
information between cells there's a lot
of communication done by cell surface
carbohydrates over here you see the
canonical structure of double-stranded
DNA we'll look at the covalent structure
of those single strands but then we'll
focus in on the non covalent
interactions that make the
double-stranded DNA and store genetic
information which is also central to
life and then lastly on this but we'll
cover this today is a lipid bilayer it's
a fascinating super molecular structure
that really is at the hearts of how all
your cells are held in a compartment
surrounded by a lipid bilayer so by the
time we start talking about those you'll
understand the forces that put in place
that lipid bilayer that arguably and
I've read articles that say this that is
the evolution of lipid bilayers is as
important as the genetic code
because if cells did not have a
surrounding did not have an inside where
you could concentrate reagents and
macromolecules and do biochemistry we
wouldn't exist as we a life wouldn't
exist in the same way okay so let's take
a look at the composition of living
systems and remarkably we are about 75%
water so most proteins are very hydrated
there's a lot of water in cells there's
a lot of water outside of cells in the
matrix and really we sort of survive
weird we survive in an aqueous
environment and the thing that you also
want to think about is when we think
about non covalent forces these are
forces put in place in water we don't
live in a on a far distant planet where
we're in sort of liquid methane or
anything like that so water is critical
to life the establishment of the
hydrosphere
when Earth earth first formed the
evolutionary events that happened after
that were - were really in hand-in-hand
with the fact that it was an aqueous
environment because forces are different
whether they are in hydrophobic
environments or hydrophilic environments
and really you'll start to get
appreciation for that as we move forward
so this basically suggests that if I put
one of you in a giant desiccator and
pumped out all the water I could
possibly pull out there'd be about sort
of depending on your weight 40 pounds of
things left behind of what's left behind
the majority of it is going to be
biological macromolecules and then the
rest of it that little sliver are things
like ions and small molecules calcium
magnesium iron manganese those are those
small inorganic ions as well as small
molecule metabolites that are involved
in central metabolisms let's go now look
at the macromolecules and they're sort
of proportions relative to each other
the smallest sliver are the lipids which
we'll talk about today then you have the
nucleic acids that are critical for
information storage you have proteins
which make the largest piece of the pie
and the carbohydrates which are one of
the is the 25% so you can see how
important carbohydrates are because of
their proportion being relatively large
the lipid proportion though is small but
absolutely critical harking back to the
membrane bilayer
because if we didn't have the membrane
bilayer once again we wouldn't have life
in the same way that we have it now so
that gives you a sense of the relative
proportions of things and frankly when I
discuss the macromolecules I really like
to start with lipids because of the
membrane bilayer but because their
structures are comparatively simple
relative to amino acids and nucleic
acids so we can get a few of the basics
of the chemical structures down and how
we render them on paper so that we can
do that with lipids which are a little
simpler now life to a chemist you have
to sort of worry about this entire mess
of the periodic table but the
good news for you is for biological
systems we deal with very focused
components of the periodic table so
those biological macromolecules are made
up largely of only six elements hydrogen
carbon nitrogen and oxygen phosphorus
and sulfur so that makes your problem
your the amount of stuff you need to
know about basic covalent structures way
more simple than it is for the average
chemist who has to worry about
everything down here in the nether
regions and whoops what are you doing
are the things that are things that are
radioactive all kinds of other things
you don't have to worry about any of
that so the covalent bonding we will
talk about is amongst those six
different elements and they make up a
ninety-eight percent of the cellular
mass and then the other components that
are important in cells are some metal
ions the alkali and alkaline earth my
elements so sodium magnesium potassium
calcium those were all quite important
in life
and then these transition metal ions
that are really important in enzyme
catalysis for example but we will not
cover very much of that but those are
what are known as trace elements that
are very as transition metal elements
that are very important for biochemistry
and then last of all there are some
rogue ones that there's even smaller
amounts in physiologic systems these are
things like chromium molybdenum and
tungsten selenium and iodine and
although certain of these elements only
have found in totally bizarre organisms
so for example you and I don't have much
molybdenum and tungsten I don't think
unless it slipped in there by accident
but you and I definitely need selenium
and iodine as trace elements does anyone
know where iodine comes and figures most
prominently yeah high right absolutely
so the thyroid hormone is a small
organic molecule with several iodine's
in it and we need absolutely need iodine
in our diets in order to build the
thyroxine hormone the pro that deals
with a lot of aspects of metabolism
we don't need a lot and if we get too
much it's bad for you but we definitely
need traces of these elements now I will
spend a very small amount of time just
laying down the basics of organic
chemistry bonding now who are view of
either taken the chemistry gir or had
high school chemistry quite recently is
that pretty much all of you and now if
you didn't put your hand out don't worry
we're here to bring you up to speed if
you need it frankly if you just know
what's on the next two or three slides
you're in great shape all the
information that you need has been
condensed but if it's a little bit out
of nowhere you could come see me in
office hours and I can just run through
things too for you and we can just get
you up to speed there is no need for pre
knowledge I just need an idea of how
much pre knowledge you have so when we
talk about covalent bonding and start to
think about the elements that are
critical for life
it's important to consider the
electronic structures of these elements
and why this why they happen to be the
chosen elements okay the most important
thing about hydrogen carbon nitrogen
oxygen phosphorus and sulfur is they
love to make covalent bonds a lot of
metal ions form salts
you know sodium chloride or many other
different salts but covalent bonds are
the main structure of our macromolecules
strong bonds between elements such as
these six in particular these six where
they share electrons in covalent bonds
rather than form ionic interactions
where somebody gives an electron to
someone else and you have a plus/minus
type interaction so these shared bonds
are important for life so it's good to
understand why hydrogen carbon nitrogen
and oxygen and then phosphorous and
sulfur are so important in order to
understand the covalent bonding of these
elements it's useful to know the
electronic configuration but you could
live without that the most important
thing is that covalent bonds such as the
one between carbon and hydrogen here Rep
reflects a
pair of electrons one from the hydrogen
one from the carbon to make a stable
covalent bond because of its electronic
configuration carbon is neutral when it
has four covalent bonds nitrogen is
neutral when it has three covalent bonds
but there's an extra lone pair of
electrons that are not forming bonds in
neutral nitrogen and oxygen is neutral
when it has two covalent bonds these
could be with hydrogen they could be
with carbon they could be with several
of the other elements for carbon we
don't deal with charge states of carbon
because they're pretty high energy they
may be high energy intermediates in an
enzyme catalyzed reaction but they're
not sitting there as high energy
intermediates in your macromolecules the
key thing you want to notice is for all
of these elements surveilance shell is
complete with eight electrons but these
lone pairs and I or bunny is as people
like to call them really feature very
prominently in biochemistry and biology
because they are places for hydrogen
bonding interactions so we run a lot on
electrostatic hydrogen bonding and
hydrophobic interactions if we know
where the lone pair electrons are we
know one part of a hydrogen bonding
interaction it turns out that in biology
we're mostly at pH 7 or in that range
except for a few subcellular
compartments but at pH 8 nitrogen lone
pair of electrons will pick up a proton
to become a positively charged nitrogen
and you'll mostly see that as a
positively charged so the sidechain of
lysine which has an NH 3 an NH 2 at the
very end of a carbon chain is most
commonly protonated and positively
charged so it could be involved in an
interaction so we can consider both the
neutral and the charged positively
charged state of nitrogen for oxygen
that oxygen lone pair will compete our
per proton to form the hydronium ion so
that's positively charged o h group so
it would have an extra proton using up a
lone
hair or and three hydrogen's or it could
give our per proton to form the
hydroxide iron and those are the states
of oxygen that are most common so in
that UV we've kind of dispatched the
those first four of the six elements
phosphorus and sulfur a little tricky
but there is some good news
[Music]
sulfur copies oxygen so you don't really
have to worry too much about sulfur
you'll just consider it to really be
sort of an older sibling of oxygen where
all the chemistry is very very similar
sulfur or the negatively charged sulfur
anion are both important phosphorus is
difference phosphorus does not tend to
show up in the version that copies
nitrogen it is it is capable of adopting
higher oxidation states and all of the
phosphorus you meet in biochemistry for
the most part there's a few odd things
in weird organisms is going to be in the
form of an oxidized form of phosphorus
which generally has one two three four
five bonds to phosphorous it can take on
a higher oxidation state and you will
see phosphorus phosphorus in the
phosphate form is absolutely essential
to life but it's the place where we
store a ton of reactivity for the
reactions of nucleotides adenosine
triphosphate adenosine diphosphate the
phosphodiester backbone in nucleic acids
phosphorylation of amino acids to form
phosphoproteins it's always in this
state with all the XD extra oxygens and
that that configuration of bonds okay if
you know this you've got a lot of the
covalent bonds under control so any
questions about this is everyone all
right I know it might be it's probably a
refresher for most of you the next thing
I just briefly want to mention is the
most typical functional groups that
occur in biological molecules
and you may say well what does it mean
functional group usually it's a place
where the action happens if you have a
large molecule that's a bunch of carbon
carbon and carbon hydrogen covalent
bonds there's not a lot going on unless
you can really rip those bonds apart but
they're high energy but functional
groups are often times where chemistry
happens or biochemistry happens so
there's the Oh H hydroxyl we as chemists
and biochemists will tend to use an R
where we mean something else
so we don't write out a whole structure
we would just put our Ohi manage us say
anything so for example if R was ch3 ch2
you would have ethanol so but but I'm
keeping it more generic the next
functional group that is important is
the carboxylate group or the carboxyl
group looks like this now when we look
at these molecules you always want to
sort of think where the lone pair
electrons are there's two on oxygen - on
oxygen - on oxygen so that actually
shows you where the rest of the
electrons are this is the carboxyl group
but in nature in physiologic systems
this shows up most commonly in its
anionic form that's important because
when we start to think of interactions
between enzymes and their substrates or
the folding of proteins were thinking of
something with a negative charge not a
neutral so this group loses a proton to
form the carboxylate group and if you
want to know where the lone pairs are
now that's what they look like so those
are two of the key ones let's now go to
nitrogen
that is the neutral Ameen but as I just
mentioned to you that will very commonly
pick up a proton and be in the
positively charged date now when I show
you both of those guys in the positively
charged State what you could immediately
tell me is that if I have an amino acid
with one of these groups and a nearby
amino acid with one of these groups they
could form an electrostatic interaction
between themselves plus and minus
complimenting each other so if you know
the charged States you're much better
off because you can tell where where
non-covalent types of ionic or
electrostatic interactions occur so
these are very important then there's
the phosphate group it's often ionized
and the sulfhydryl group so phosphate
the sulfhydryl group is also called the
file group and i'm sure i've spelt that
wrong because hydral they look like that
and the most common state are the South
hydral or not the most common can also
appear as the anionic structure so
that's the basic functional groups now
there are two more functional group
assemblies that you will see a lot in
physiologic systems that are basically
composites of some of these structures
because when we have single building
blocks we need to join them to each
other through different types of
chemistry's so I want to show you the
types of chemistry that you get by
forming a composite the height of a
hydroxyl and the carboxyl group and a
composite of a carboxyl group and in the
mid because the polymer that's the
protein polymer has building
blocks that have a means and carboxyls
but they're all put together into a
polymeric structure where those groups
have been joined in a condensation
polymer so let me just show you what
those look like and then we'll be done
with the functional groups so there are
the first one because I've drawn them in
this order okay
it's the amide and the other one
is the esta when you do these two
reactions if you do them in the lab
they're called condensation reactions
because as you form that bond you pick
out a molecule of water these are really
important new functional groups to you
because your proteins are held together
by a made groups in fact they're so
important in proteins we often call them
peptide groups you'll see more about
that on Monday and the esters are really
important for example in derivatives of
glycerol that make fatty acids or
phospholipids you'll see esters
occurring again and again the other
composite group that you can also see is
with the phosphate plus an alcohol and
what that group looks like is as follows
and you're going to see this sort of
endlessly in nucleic acids let's keep
the charges all even here and this is
what's known as the phosphate ester okay
and that is yet another condensation
where you kick out water alright so
let's just run back to this image and we
can sum it all up those are all the
groups that I just described to you and
if you want you can go back and put lone
pairs of electrons on everything and
then the composite groups that I want to
mention to you in particular are the
amide and the ester and they're very
important in physiologic systems they
are the bond that holds together the
biopolymer in many cases not shown him
on this picture is the phosphate ester
i've added that
this year because it's kind of important
is a similar condensation reaction
between phosphorus and an alcohol and
that in particular is what the bond
you'll see that holds together nucleic
acids and now one sort of thing that we
won't go into a lot of detail I want you
to notice that this nitrogen here has a
lone pair of electrons it picks up a
proton very readily the amide nitrogen
is not so willing to pick up a proton
because it messes up the rest of its
chemistry so that nitrogen in an ami
tends to be observed as a neutral
however that hydrogen can be involved in
hydrogen bonds ok any questions about
that before we move on to non covalent
bonds it's everything clear now I try to
put everything in one place so you have
it in front of you what I've put on
those two slides is what you need to
know about organic covalent bonding it
doesn't go beyond it this I will say
there's a tiny bit of memorization but
once you commit that stuff to memory you
know you're in a good place with respect
to understanding how the molecules of
life were put together ok yeah what is
more important to me once we've put
those structures in place is non
covalent bonding
because to mean on covalent bonding is
synonymous with dynamics courses that
can be readily broken and reassembled
broken and reassembled the energy the
strength of a typical bond between two
carbons or a carbon and hydrogen is on
the order of 90 to 100 kilocalories per
mole it takes a lot to break those bonds
we can't break them at will to go and do
some biological activity but the range
of energies of the non covalent bonds
are far more modest they range from so
this is covalent but the non covalent
ranged from one maybe to about 10
kilocalories per mole
so when you think about those forces
they're readily broken and made broken
and made and what's so amazing about
protein and nucleic acid structure is
that you can you can gradually break a
bond while you're making another non
covalent bond so you can have the
dynamics of the structure that define a
lot of its functional properties because
structures are dynamic an enzyme that's
a composite of a lot of non covalent
interaction combined a substrate can
gradually form a set of covalent bonds
with that substrate but then can start
changing in the shape of that structure
and that shape in order to go through a
catalytic cycle to do chemistry and then
to liberate products that is all driven
by changes in covalent bonding non
covalent bonding subtle changes that
occur without big energy barriers that
would be necessary to break the non
covalent partner covalent bonds so shown
at the top here you see the average bond
energy of covalent bonds the small
number is something for example between
two chlorines that's a pretty weak bond
but of course we
have a lot of them running around so
really carbon hydrogen carbon carbon
they're at the higher end there about a
hundred kilocalories 80 kilocalories per
mole the other important interactions
though that make up the non covalent
interactions are as follows so the first
important one is the ionic bond it is
also called a salt bridge or an
electrostatic interaction why we give
three names for this probably comes from
which which type of chemists decided to
define them they are all the same things
they are basically interactions between
a positively charged entity a protonated
amine and a negatively charged entity a
deprotonated carboxylate those are about
the strongest of the non covalent bonds
but it's very variable because it
depends a lot on their environment
if those two entities are in a
hydrophobic environment they're gonna
charge right for each other to form a
strong electrostatic interaction but if
those are out in water each of those
groups could be solvated by water and
they'd have to give up salvation in
order to form a good electrostatic
interaction when we talk about protein
folding we'll go into that in a little
bit more detail so the reason why this
says very variable is not to drive you
crazy it's just they're very variable
and they're but they will still range I
would say from 2 to 10 kilocalories so
those are important easy to pick out the
strongest of the set if dr. a gives you
a problem set and starts asking you to
pick out non covalent interactions
that's the one you you take care of
straight away because it is the most
obvious the next most important though
is the hydrogen bond now
hydrogen bonds have been known to
mystified people for years because
people are how do I pick these things
out how do I pick things things out I'm
going to give you a foolproof way of
picking out hydrogen bonds so you will
never be at a loss for hydrogen bonds
okay well how do we recognize them they
are between hydrogen's that are on
electronegative elements such as oxygen
of course there's other things attached
here or on nitrogen or on sulfur so all
of those three functional groups can
serve as hydrogen bond donors they can
give a proton in a hydrogen bond and
share that proton between a hydrogen
bond acceptor okay so these are all
gonna be known as donors so you can
recognize them this company is not a
hydrogen bond donor carbons got his
hydrogen and it's not giving it away to
anybody for love or money it's hold on
tight so this is not a hydrogen bond
donor okay now what are the
hydrogen-bond acceptors are places where
that hydrogen would want to sit yes
actually they just they could be double
or they could be single but I was just
putting them so that you see that the
nitrogen has one two three bonds to it
okay yeah it could alternatively also be
the form of nitrogen just to confuse you
it has an extra proton it could be the
protonated version because that can
still be a hydrogen bond donor okay now
what are the hydrogen-bond acceptors
they are any place where you have a lone
pair so let's just think of a carbonyl
group two lone pairs a hydroxyl group
two lone pairs a nitrogen that is not
protonated one lone pair those are the
hydrogen-bond acceptors so as long as
you know your structures in the Cova in
the in the functional groups and you
know where the lone pairs are you can
figure out where there could be a
hydrogen bond so these all of these
types are acceptors okay so in protein
biochemistry for example those kinds of
hydrogen bonding is very very important
to form the three-dimensional structures
of proteins and the reason why is
because in a protein proteins are made
up of amid bonds where this h n can be a
donor
this Oh can be an acceptor and you can
get networks of hydrogen bonding
interactions to establish structures of
proteins when a small molecule binds to
a protein it may look to fit in a place
where it can maximize electrostatic
interactions and the hydrogen bonding
interactions so we'll ask you to start
to be able to take out hydrogen bonding
so here you saw the electrostatic
interaction here is a typical hydrogen
bonding interaction between a hydroxyl
and a carbonyl group
I couldn't spot that very readily unless
I remembered that there were lone pairs
of electrons there okay the other two -
any questions about that any questions
about hydrogen bonding are you
comfortable with thinking you could
derive your way to figuring out where
they are you'll see them used a lot so
they'll become more and more familiar to
you as you move forward okay good the
last two types of interactions
are the hydrophobic interactions and
vongavel forces I never get a spelling
right but I'll get the concepts over you
now hydrophobic interactions are
incredibly important so when you think
of folding a protein driven solely by
electrostatic interactions and hydrogen
bonding you have a bit of a problem
because all of those groups are hydrogen
bonded to water so you'd have to get rid
of the water before they could make
interactions with each other that makes
sense because we're in water we're
folding in water hydrophobic
interactions are really great because
they want to form in water if you're
making you know a batch of salad
dressing oil and vinegar and you shake
it up what happens it separates the oil
goes to top the vinegar goes to the
bottom why because of hydrophobic
interactions in the oil phase so if you
have a large protein that has a bunch of
hydrophobic groups they will want to
collapse out of the water to interact
with each other and then hydrogen
bonding and electrostatic will fall into
place
so hydrophobic interactions are a very
important and vital force in nature in
the non covalent bonding so that's those
of 'literally interactions amongst
molecules that have a lot of ch and CC
bonds the final force that's shown up
there is the band of ARs force and we
don't worry too much about that but it
is simply the interaction between very
weakly polarized hydrogen carbon
hydrogen or other types of bonds where
there's a little bit of difference
between the little bit of a dipole
between the bond and they form little
dipolar interactions but mostly I think
you really want to focus on the
electrostatic the hydrogen bond and the
hydrophobic these are more minor and
it's a little bit of a subtlety so let's
focus on those three all right
so with that said the key thing for you
what do you need to be able to do is
understand them and recognize them in
complex systems
lastly I'm just going to leave this it's
going to stay in your notes we you know
get in biochemistry tend to use line
angle drawings it's kind of complicated
to draw these sort of great big things
with all the hydrogen's and oxygens and
stuff spelled out so we use the line
angle drawing there's some shown here
for different molecules and the rules
are laid out so that you can go and just
figure out through a bit of practicing
and just figure out the line angle
drawing them what it means basically
every line represents a bond every
vertex represents a carbon atom but what
you do show on the drawings that are non
carbon atoms so for example oxygen or
nitrogen and when you show you imply the
hydrogen's that are bonded to carbon but
you have to show the hydrogen's that are
on nitrogen or oxygen for example and
you have to figure out what your charge
state might be so I'm gonna leave you
with that alright okay so what we've
learned so far is these basic forces in
biology are critical for the Assembly of
the building blocks of biological
macromolecules what I want to talk to
you about now and well probably because
I've spent a little bit of time on that
spill over a little more to next week
but I'm going to talk to you about the
first class of macromolecules which are
the lipids so what makes something a
lipid these are the most sort of
complicated mixture of biological
molecules and formally they're not
really macromolecules they're small
molecules but what's common to all of
them is that they are very rich in
carbon carbon and carbon hydrogen bonds
because all of these the line angle
drawings of all of these would suggest
to you that the dominant feature of all
these molecules is a bunch of C C and CH
bonds which makes the molecules quite
hydrophobic there are no functional
groups there and and they behave very
differently for example they would have
a tough time dissolving in water
in some cases and so this complicated
looking set of molecules can be
distilled out as being very rich in
carbon hydrogen and carbon carbon bonds
and we call those collectively lipids
now in they have a lot of different
functions so for example triglycerides
such as shown here with 3 ester bonds a
storage for energy things like estradiol
things like steroids they have this 6 6
5 6 5 arrangement of rings all your
steroid hormones kind of look like that
a lot of Ch bonds there are some
vitamins so for example retinol is a
vitamin it's also a lipid and then there
are the phospholipids shown down here I
just briefly want to mention a little
bit about retinol and retinol which have
crucial retinol is a critical vitamin it
comes actually from carotene which is a
molecule that you find in a lot of
orange and yellow fruits such as carrots
but the oxidized products of retinol is
this lipid called retinol which is
central to the process of vision so
retinol binds to proteins that sit in
the membrane when light shines on them
the shape of the retinol changes it goes
from a particular configuration of the
double bond to a different one the shape
just changes and that sends a signal to
your brain so lipids are important
absolutely essential in vision and sight
because they're involved in the
signaling process because their shapes
change and send signals other types of
lipids are these things and we call them
fatty acids mostly because they're
greasy long-chain acids with a long
hydrophobic tail and the hydrophilic end
group here these molecules are also what
are known as antha Pathak because they
have a sort of split personality they
have a hydrophobic moiety and a
hydrophilic moiety whenever you see
see at the beginning of a word it means
in both so both hydrophilic and and and
lipophilic so these are important and
these are very important components
you've probably heard a lot of press
about some of the fatty acids and how
bad trans fats are you for you and how
you should be careful to make sure your
diet is rich in sis fats or rather than
trans fats because the trans fats are
contributors to coronary heart disease
so you may wonder what's the
relationship between heart disease and
these two types of lip affiliate
components which are in the body so let
me describe to you that relationship
remember the cysts are rich in things
like the the nut oils and fruit oils
such as olive oil so coronary heart
disease is associated with trans fats
what's the linkage what's the biology in
that so clicking it comes the story is
related to cholesterol cholesterol is a
critical component in our membranes the
trouble is we have to be able to move
cholesterol around but it's so
hydrophobic it doesn't dissolve in water
okay so in the body your cholesterol is
moved around in the form of lipoproteins
the bind to the cholesterol and take it
to the different organs where it is
needed all right and so the lipoproteins
can either be low-density and associate
with cholesterol or they can be
high-density and those also associate
with cholesterol the high-density
lipoproteins are kind of large the in
fact they're fairly agile they don't
stick the arteries and vesicles vessels
and they can be excreted in the liver or
move around the bloodstream without any
problem
it's the low-density ones that are
problems because they're low-density and
they kind of stick to the walls of your
arteries and start making build ups and
then plaques which contribute to heart
disease
so the low-density ones have cholesterol
but they're very small sticky and it's a
physical interaction with your blood
vessels and they start to clog your
arteries what's the relationship to
saturated and
spats is that they increase for
low-density lipoprotein in preference to
the high-density so if you have a lot of
trans fats you make a lot of low-density
lipoproteins it's trying to carry
cholesterol around but it gets stuck to
your blood vessels and you start to clog
your blood vessels for heart that
contributes to heart disease
so these lipophilic molecules are
important they have places to store
energy they are critical to hormones and
signaling for example but there are some
complications with disease because
certain types of fatty acids contribute
to heart disease
yeah no no it's it's the the density is
in the of the entire physical particle
it's a nanoparticle that would be more
float would show a different density
respect to how it floats in water so the
density is really the physical metric of
the entire particle as opposed to just
the molecule it might be different
because of the way it compact but it
that the important thing about the trans
fats is that they really contribute to
making the protein the forms are low
density particles okay all right so I'm
just going to introduce these not
quickly but I'll show you some cool
images in a at the beginning of the next
class this is the last group of lipid ik
molecules and they are actually oops
esters and phospho esters of fatty acids
with glycerol this is a small molecule
that forms esters through its oxygens to
these long chains and also to phosphate
and these contribute to really important
functions in the body
they are also amphipathic because they
have a hydrophobic component and a
hydrophilic component and we often draw
them in a shorthand form like this that
represents this head group and these
tails and I want to just leave you with
this wonderful image of the sorts of
supera molecular structures that these
kinds of phospholipids come for
so super molecular molecular it's a very
important term in biology as it is in
engineering super molecular it means
it's a structure that's above the
molecular level it's a an aggregation of
different molecules to make a super
molecule with different properties from
the individual components phospholipids
self-assemble that's another important
into supra molecular structures that are
very very important in living systems
some of them are just useful in other
sorts of engineering approaches such as
lipice ohms and micelles but the most
important super molecular structure of a
phospholipid is the lipid bilayer
that surrounds your cells and what
happens is you simply put those
molecules the phospholipids in water and
they will sell assemble on their own
into these super molecular structures
whether they form micelles or lipice
ohms or bilayers is dependent very much
on the tails of the lipids what sorts of
shapes and structures you get but in
physiology and human physiology the
phospholipids that we have want to form
these bilayer structures that have
incredibly important properties most
importantly that they are semi permeable
and they can wrap form the boundary to
certain cells so I will continue with
the final discussion of this on Monday
before we move forward to the amino
acids peptides and proteins and I just
quickly want to move you to ask you for
Monday to try to catch a read of the
section 3.2 in the text if you have a
chance it'll give you a nice preview
you